サッブ パパッサーサ アカラナン クサラッサー ウパ サンプラ サチッタ パリヨ ダパナン エータン ブッダナ サーサナン
はい ではよろしくお願いいたします
と 今日のテーマはね 共に歩むということで
共に歩むんだけど 共に承認じゃなくて
自立を目指す道なんですね
そこはちょっと勉強した方がいいポイントもありますね
解脱は一人でということで
しかし 仏教はグループ活動っていうのはすごい大事にしているんですね
この矛盾は何なのかっていうことも勉強した方がよろしいとは思います
では まずは今日の お布施の
今日のお墓入りのお布施でございます
前田真理子様と井出伸子様という二人のお布施でございます
皆様にはこの二人の方の特別に何か期待願望っていうのはなさそうでね
平気で教えているものがしでありますようにという気持ちで
というお布施ですからね
なおさら素晴らしいお布施だと思いますね
で 何か期待して見返りがあってお布施する場合は
まあそれはちょっと小さくなるんですね
少々 で ただ仏法僧のために行じたいという気持ちだけで
ものすごい無料のところにはなります
ですから このお二方に三宝のご加護がありますように
解脱に達するまで 悩み苦しみに不幸に縁がないようにと誓願いたします
それから 家族の皆様方
親戚の皆様方にも同じく幸福でありますように
悩み苦しみがなく 無くなりますように
解脱に達することができますようにと誓願いたします
サードゥ サードゥ サードゥ
はい 順番でテーマ進んでいきますが
できるだけ早く終わりにしようかなという考えはあるんです
皆様にはこのテーマに関係ないいろいろな質問もあるだろうと思いますので
で いきなりわけもわからないけど
私は自立していますと他人に依存しているとはとは思いたくはない
これっていうのは普通の人々の気持ちなんですね
みんな自立していると思っているんです
それについてちょっと
世間的独立 自立 独立 あまり私は単語にこだわってないんだからね
いろいろその時その時言葉使います
はい で 我々はだいたいあの人
私は自立している 私はもう独立しているとかね
いろんなこと言ってますね
それその深い意味があるのかと
で そこはこういうことなんです
生活できる収入があること
それで自立しているというんです
プラスアルファの収入があればなおさら嬉しいんですね
それでバンバンさん自立していますね
独立していますと思っているんです
しかし 収入のために社会に依存しなくていい
依存しなくてはならないでしょう
そうすると プラスマイナスで何のこともないんですね
だから収入が必要で それは自立したって収入を得るためには
朝から晩まで会社の奴隷にならなくちゃいけないですね
どこが自立とかよくわからなくなっちゃうんですね
それから親戚との関係を薄めて
独身が自分の家族を中心にして生きることことをも
自立だが これちょっと文章はちょっとなんか分かりにくくなりましたね
誰が書いたんですか？考えても私ですね
次の自立のテーマは この家族
親との関係をすごく薄めちゃう
まあ年に一回ぐらい電話かけるだけ
それ自立してると思ってるんですね
あるいはこの 独身の人々は自分だけ中心に生きているんですね
まあ他誰も私に入らん
関係ないっていうね あるいはもう一人の人々は
自分の家族 自分の奥さんと子供たちだけで
もう十分 もう他の人はいらんという感じで
それで私は独立しているんだと
この気持ちは女性によくあるんですね
結婚したら旦那と一緒に別な家を買って
そちらに住みたいんですね
親戚から離れて あれもまあ自立したいんですね
で それもまたかえって変なんですね
これただの行動範囲のことでしょ
行動範囲が狭いことを自慢していますね
これ自立ですかね 悪く言えばもう極端な臆病者なんですね
隠れて隠れて だからそんな自立と独立っていうのはね
それは社会が考えているところでしょうに
新しく結婚したならば
奥さんにとってはマイホームがあって
旦那と一緒に別に生活できればもう最高
自分がものすごい偉いんですね
旦那の親の家で実家で
ものすごく気持ち悪くて惨めって思っていてね
ああ 独立しなくちゃと
自立しなくちゃって言って
どこかのアパート マンション買ったり借りたりしてっていうのは
だからこれはただ行動範囲を狭くする
だからその独立自立もなんか仏教的な分析から見ると
ああって感じになるんですね
そうですかっていう感じになるんです
独身の人 結局は独身の人
にしても変ですね ネットに友達に依存しています
だからうるさいってるんです
私は一人で生活していますよと言って
朝から晩までネットをいじってるんだからね
なんか変です はい それからこれは社会的独立ですね
性格的な独立もあります
他人と一緒に生活しても
自分は単独行動する 家族の中に一人ですけど
家族で全然もうコミュニケーション何もなく
もうもうご飯作ってあったらのは行って食べたりして
あるいはよくいるんですね
あのもう年聞いたら 48
38  40とかですけど
お母さん料理作って部屋の前に置いとかなくちゃいけないんですね
で 食べてそのまま外で皿を出すだけで
えらい独立してますね
その場合は性格ですね
自分の考えのみを重視する
そういうふうに引きこもりでなくても
いつでも自分の考え 自分の考え
自分の好き嫌い 自分の好みに
で みんなそこでもう抑えなくちゃいかんですね
そういう性格的に自分が独立してるつもりなんです
他人の考え 気持ちなどは無視する
否定する 拒否する 私には私の考えがあるんだから
効率的に生きていると
あんたが言うことっていうのはまるっきり気にしませんよという独立
それも性格独立なんですね
社会がその人に協力することをできるだけ控える
結果として そんな人のこと
みんなもう嫌悪するんですね
引きこもりだったら 産んだ親にしてもね
気持ち悪くてしょうがないんですね
まあ親も親で性格悪いんだから追い出さないんですね
あの連中を ある人は言ったんで
追い出せ 追い出せませんね
まあでも自分の家で実家であれ
だったらあんたアパート借りて引っ越ししなさい
あなたの息子がそんなに威張ってるんだったら
そんなに暴力まで振るうならば
常識が一切絡みがないならば
あんた姑すってどこかにアパートにでも引っ越しして
まるっきり関係ない あんたにも何か年金とかあるでしょうね
生活しなさいよ  そんな乱暴なこと
乱暴なことじゃないんです
私はしっかりと生き方を教えてるんです
私が言ったことやったら
一度誰にも間違った結果ないんです
が やった人がいるのかって
またデータ的な問題もありますけど
しかし 社会と周りの協力がないと生きられません
そこの矛盾っていうのは
例えば引きこもりのバカであっても
親がご飯作ってドアのそばに置いとかないと
食ったものをそのまま洗っても置かないんだから
その人々がそれ理解できない
自分がすごい惨めで 捨てような捨て猫みたいな感じで
出した餌食べて生活している
餌出さなかったら死ぬ範囲になるんです
そんな独立は独立なのかと
はい それ一番極端な悪い例なんですよ
我々は常識な世界でもすごいわがままで
人の話聞かないで 頑固で
一匹狼主義で生きている人々は結構いますよ
別に精神的な問題はないんだけど
で 会社でも学校でも そういう生活になってくると
まあやっぱりみんななんとなく協力しようかな
やめようかな 逃げようかなという気持ちで
それでもいるんですね
いくらわがままで一匹狼的でっていうんで
その言葉が合ってるかどうか分かりませんだけど
あの なんか独裁的で もう会社の社長解析したっても
社員たちが協力しなきゃ
言う通りにやってくれなきゃ
何もならん 何にもならんでしょうに
またそれいやいやでやっているんだからかっこいいですよ
うちの社長はすごいとは誰も言わないんだからね
飲み屋さん以外は それも社長がいる時はね
だからそんな人々は普通ノーマルなんですけど
やっぱりこの性格 独立なんですね
だからひどい目に遭うんですよ
結局は だからそういう人
突然奥さんがね 本人も年取って退職して
まあなんとかもうしようがないけど
奥さんが離婚しなさいと
そういう素晴らしい結果にもなります
私は子供たちに別してもう出られます
あるいはあんたも家を出て行ってくださいと
で なきゃ裁判かけてやるぞと
そういうことにもなります
それからこの性格 性格独立者は孤独で悩む結果になります
最初はなんか気分いいように感じますけど
すぐ間もないうちにものすごい孤独感で
もう精神がもうすり減らしてすり減らしてすごい苦しいことになります
そういうことが性格独立なんです
幸せを感じないんですね
うん はい それで世間が言う独立について
もう私のもう脳みそが壊れているんだから
今はね まあ自分で考えられる範囲でまとめました
私は扱ってないものがあったら
後で質問の時間で このポイントはどうでしょうかと教えてください
はい それからこの診断します
一つはみんな自由になりたい
みんな独立したい みんな自立したい
しかし よく考えると あんなようなね
社会的独立 性格的独立
そんなもんであって 良くではない独立になっているんです
ではなぜそういう風になるのかという
まあ診断していきましょう
で まあだからあの理由を出して理由を出して納得する時間ない
させる時間ないんだから
まあ仏教のポイントだけ言います
皆様 何回も何百回も聞いていることをですね
皆にある自我の錯覚 これが問題の種なんですね
真理に目覚めていない生命には必ず自我の錯覚があります
しょうがない 悟っていないならば
自我の錯覚があります
気づいていてもいなくても
自分が偉いんです 言わなくたっても
みんな自分が偉いと思っているんです
うーん だから自分自身が太陽で
他の生命がみんな惑星として回ってくださいという態度でみんな生きてるんですね
この気持ちはすべての生命に悩み
苦しみを作ります この自我の錯覚があるから
自分が偉いと思っているんだから
私こそ偉い偉いという人が社会から打たれますから
いくらかいくらか調教できますけど
みんな偉い 言わないね
だからどうにもならんですね
もっとひどいのは気づいてもない
だからなんで人間が悩み苦しむのかと
この自分が偉いと自分中心に考えるからなんですね
悩み苦しみがあることを皆知ってます
しかし 人間は面白いんです
普通 人間は自分には悩みがある
問題がある 苦しみがある
いろいろトラブルがあるとか
いくらでもありますよ
無限にあると思ってるんで
時々私はあなたの悩み全部言ってください
言っちゃうと 一つ二つ見ついてまた元に戻って
またまた説明しながら
またその見ついてまた元に戻してと
もう 3時間近く経っても終わらないんです
それで私もイライラするんだから
あのね 再生はいりません
私は一回で覚えますからと
言うんです 言ったらはい
わかりましたと言ってまた再生するんです
だから人間は自分が自分に悩み苦しみがあると人類知ってます
うまくいってない しかし
それを正す 正す 正しくなくす方法は知らないんです
悩み苦しみがあると知っているならば
それなくせばいいでしょうに
どうすればなくすものかとわからないんです
あの 皆様は理解できます
この例え 例えば病気になった
病気だとわかるでしょ？調子が悪いとわかるでしょ
しかし どうすればいい？わからない
こういう病気になったんだから
こういう風にこういう風にすれば
これはすぐ治りますよと知ったら
知ってるならば問題ないんです
だから我々は病気になっちゃうと
よくその同じシステムが働くんです
病気です 困ります 悩みます
苦しいんです 治りたい
健康になりたい しかし
方法は知らない 人間の歴史は苦しみをなくす強力だと言えるのです
努力だと言えるのです
じゃあ人類の歴史 この石器時代からずっとありますね
学校で学ぶ歴史じゃないんで
あんな嘘よく学ぶんですね
必要ないんです 本物の歴史は
誰か頭イカれた独裁者のことをね
あいつはいつ生まれたか
どんな時政権手を取ったのか
誰を殺したのか と これ計算しながら何年何年何月とか
無駄ですね あの努力は
はい  人類の歴史では 人類が頑張って頑張って頑張ってきて
世界どんどんどんどん変わって変わって変わっていくんですね
なんで人類が世間を変えるんですかね
苦しいからなんです 調子が悪いからなんです
もっとベターな方法ないのかと思ってるからなんです
こうすれば楽ちんだ こうすれば楽ちんだとずっと
地球上で人類が現れてどれぐらい時間経ってるんですかね
ちょっとそんなことを言うつもりはなかったんだから
データ調べてないんですけどね
結構相当経ってるでしょうね
頑張ってますよ 人類は頑張ってます
苦しみなくすために ですから
人類の歴史とは この苦しみをなくす努力
で それで文明 文化 テクノロジーなどなどが現れてるんでしょうね
例えば森に行って餌を拾って食べるものを拾うっていうのは苦しいんですよ
あったりなかったり それででは食べられるものは自分がそこら辺に育てましょうと
で 解決しましたね 森に行って
もう食べられる食べるものは得る
取れるか取れないかという不安が消えたんですね
住んでるそこら辺で自分が植えたんだからね
食べるもの でもうまくいかないね
希望通りには成長しない
もっとひどいことは 野生の動物たちが来てくる
食べちゃう ああ 困ったと
では作物を作りましょうとかね
それから試行錯誤で こういう風に水をあげればいいやとかね
芋を育ててるならば こんな土の方がいい
ホウレンソウは当時なかったんだけど
ホウレンソウだったらこのような畑作った方がいいと
トウモロコシの場合はこんな感じでよろしいとかね
だから水があまりないところで
こういうこういうものを育てましょうと
水がいっぱいあるところじゃ
こういうこういうものを
ずっと時間かかりましたよ
それからこの科学的にもういろいろ分析して
もう肥料も開発して 今はどんな程度で光を与えた方が
どんな量与えた方がいいとまで計算しているんです
だから今 あの建物の中で
ビルの下で ビルの上でもね
もうトマトとか育てられます
きれいなトマトをすごい均等に
形も色も味も同じで だって人工照明だから計算してこれぐらい光が当たった方がよろしいと
それでスイッチオフになる
そういう風に人間の歴史っていうのは
この悩み苦しみをなくそう
なくそう なくそうという努力の歴史です
しかし 面白いことがあるんです
努力は確かにやってます
今 テクノロジーの世界になっています
宇宙まで壊してやろうと思っているんです
しかし 悩み苦しみはそのまま
今は2022年になってるんだけど
200年  100年ぐらい前にあったあいつの財産を奪ってやろうという
原始的な思考で 今イランに戦争を引き起こそうとやってるでしょうに
だから獣みたいな精神でしょ
何があってあんなことをやっていますかね
何か困ったことでもある
ただ頭いかれているだけ
イラン人が自分勝手な自分の文化を守って
自分の信仰を守って平和でいることは気に入らん
殺さなくちゃなる なんで殺すのかって？あの石油
まあだからまあ 私は獣と言っても本人たちが苦しんでるんです
あ 大変だ 食い物なくなった
と言って あの原始人になった怯えがトランプさんにもあるんです
いまだに あの人の話を聞いていたんだけどね
ああ こいつは石器時代の人間と同じや
すごい怯えてるんだとか
やっつけたよとかね 法律違反なことをやって
それで人類が幸せになりますね
だって日本も言ってアメリカを応援しなくちゃあかんでしょ
第3世界戦争を引き起こすために
私はわからない なんでイランのことを放っておかないんですかね
それ人間でしょうに その人々は自分の石油を売って
それなりに幸せか不幸せか
どうでもいいでしょ 生きてるんだから
イラン人にはなんとかフリーダムがないやとかね
関係ないでしょうに ホメイニが独裁者って
もう関係ないでしょうに
隣の家の旦那さんがすごい痩せてます
あなたに関係ないでしょう
そんなのは 隣の隣の隣の家の旦那さんがすごい背が低い
ああいや だ 我慢できない
そういう話でしょ だからイカれてない？イランが自分勝手で何やっても
それはそちらのことで
こちらに関係ない イランが日本やら自分の国でも同じですけど
大量に石油を売ってるで
安く 国境の拷問も関係なく
個人 個人友人関係で売ってるんだから
私は最高と思いますよ
だからその場合はあなた方に売るものなんかあったら買ってあげますよとか
これも買うし うちの石油ちょっといいよと
だからまあそれがダメっていうのはね
アメリカが気に入る国からしか石油を買ってはいけないと指令するのはね
どこに書いた法律ですかね
はい  そういうことで このいまだに
例えば日本人よりその国の人々はすごく怯えて
あ 財産なくなったら怖い
どうしよう 食い物なくなったらとか言って
で アメリカ人も怯えているんです
だから病気なんです 日本はそんなに怯えてないんだけど
でもそれも仇になっちゃってね
今負けてるんだからね
経済大国でいたんだけどね
今はあれはなんて言いますか
エンシェントロインズというものになっているんです
だからある程度で無常だから状況変わるかもっていうちょっとした注意も必要なんですけど
それは病気になるまで増やす必要はないんですね
だから私の仏教の法話のポイントは
ご苦労さん 人類が ずっと頑張ってるんです
でも問題はそのまんま
人間の悩み 苦しみはそのままということは
正しい治療法はやってないんですね
それから これ自我の問題ですよ
このイリュージョンのフリーダムというものがあるんですね
それは日本語に訳できないから
そのまま放っておいたんです
まあイリュージョンなら幻覚って意味なんですね
フリーダムっていうのは大体みんなご存知でしょう
自我のせいで人は自由だと議論します
人は自由でしょう 自由なら立証する必要も議論する必要もないでしょう
で ヨーロッパ哲学などなどを読んでみてください
人は自由であるとものすごく大蔵式に議論する
分厚い論文を書くんです
頭どうかなっているんです
人は自由だったら言う必要ないでしょう
でも 一つも論文見つかったんですか？我々は人間であると証明する
ない だって人間だから別に証明する必要ないでしょう
他の生命と見ると 猿もいるし
ヘビもいるし 鳥たちもいるし
人間もいる それでカテゴライズしてホモサピエンス
話は終わり 誰が論文を書く？我々はホモサピエンスである
こういうわけにとかないんです
ただ特色を見てちょっとラベル貼っただけ
しかし 人間は自由でした
フリーウィルあるかないか
フリーでどのように使うのか
議論するわするわするわ
それでわかるでしょうに
ちょっとおかしいと なんで自由があるのかと議論する気持ちになるんですかね
自我があるんですね だからわがままできてきたいんですね
ちょっとやろうとしてしまうとうまくいかないんですね
それで腹が立って議論するんです
例えば教会は人間は神のロボット
神がすでにスイッチを押してるんだから
その通りに動きなさいと
しかし 神が信仰しなさいと言ってるんですね
教会はそれで困るんですね
ロボットだったら信仰するようにスイッチ押せばいいでしょうに
あるいはちょっとしたちょっとしたプログラム入れちゃえばね
だいたいあんな風なプログラムを書くためには
大体10行テンライントゥエンティラインでできます
ああいうプログラムを書く必要がないんです
だからAというファクターがあって B
というファクターがあって B
がAを信仰するべきはある
それでこれは困る 信仰する人間もいる
信仰しない人間もいるし
どうしようかと じゃあ信仰しないんで殺してやるかやろうかなと思ったら殺しきれないね
あ 神が自由を与えたと新しいことを考えちゃう
それで教会は人を搾取するんだから
それに腹が立った連中が
まあ自由 人間は自由です
あれこれですとか また議論する
まあ両方もう頭イカれてるだけの話ですから
説明する必要ないんです
思考は自由だと言えます
それなら思考は自由だと言えますね
言論の自由があると言います
本当にある？言論の自由
何言ってますかね 仏教では喋るならば道徳ありますと言ってるでしょう？だから自由がないんです
私は喋るということは私の言葉を理解できる人間がいなかったら意味がないでしょうに
私はどこかの木の前で説法したからといって意味がないでしょうね
思考は自由だと では このネガティブ思考で精神的に病気になっているヒステリー症状を起こしちゃう人々に妄想やめて言ってみて
明るい思考で生きてみてと言ってみてみてください
自由じゃないんで あんな汚い支離滅裂な妄想がぐちゃぐちゃぐちゃぐちゃぐちゃぐちゃぐちゃぐちゃやっているんですよ
だから思考の自由なんか何なのかと
だから思考にも道徳が必要です
道徳で管理するべきだったら
自由ということにならないんですね
凧は自由じゃないんで
糸があるんですよ あれ
糸がある限り凧は美しく空を飛んでいるんです
糸を切れたらすぐ瞬間で落下するから
判断の自由がある また判断の自由があるんだと
もうだから自由はたくさんありますよ
だからまとめてイリュージョンのフリーダム
いろんな種類の自由があるんです
人間が考える 一つは判断の自由
自由な人間で生まれるとも言います
で 生まれる時は自由でしたけど
今は本当にもう変ですね
自由じゃないんだから
生まれてみたら自由じゃないけど
生まれる時自由でした
お前知ってるのかと聞きたくなるんです
生まれる時は自由で BORN FREE と
よくあんなこと言う BORN
FREE じゃないでしょうに
ただのあれでしょ？奇跡でしょ
赤ちゃんたちは 母親のお腹から出たからといって
まだおっぱいにぶら下がっていないと
誰がBORN FREE というんですかね
思考はもううるさいんだからね
人間が では思考は自由になるんだと
だから考えたら考えた自由欲しい自由
見つからないでしょ じゃあ死後
死後で自由になるんだとね
そう思っているんです
死んだらみんな仏になるんだと
いい考えですね 頭のイカれた人にとっては
私はアホやと思いますけどね
自分で判断できて 自分で行動して生きてる時も
仏の一欠けらもなかった人は寝たきりになって意識もなくなっちゃって
危篤状態になっちゃって
呼吸止まっちゃったら
もう成仏する はぁ 何考えて
だからこの死後自由になるというけど
あなた知ってるのかい？と聞けば
この私は今 この世界で膨大な哲学の議論があっても
ほんの一言葉でなんだこれということになるんです
絶対的な神が創造し管理するのだと言いますね
自由を探して見つからない場合は
もう全部パターンで動くんだから
やっぱりボスがいるんだと
人間を管理すると ボスがいることどうやって知ってるんですかね
だって我々作られたものだから
作ったやつは知らんでしょうね
ああ あなたを私が作ったと
もう作って終わってるんだから
作る過程で知ってるならば
ああ この人私を作っているんだ
今足のところ 今お腹のところ
今胸のところを作っているんだとかね
知ってることできれば
すべて自我の錯覚病の症状です
それは今まで言ったのはすべて自我の錯覚の症状です
自我がすべて問題を作るんです
では 個人に行きましょう
個人にも問題があるんです
おかげさまで生かされている
他人に迷惑かけてはいけない
人の役に立つ人間にならなくては
調和平和を保たなくては
みな平等だ みな仲良くすべきだなどの考えを持つ人々はたくさんいますね
かっこいいね 問題はその希望が叶っていないことです
考えはかっこいいんだけど
叶ってないでしょ 例えば日本社会だけ皆様知ってるんだからね
こういう前に書いたものを皆さんは持ってる気持ちなんです
人に他人に迷惑をかけてはいけませんとか
これは日本の方々はみんな同じ気持ちだったら
おもてつらいはずでしょうに
叶ってないんですね 結局は
その目的を目指しても弊害がありすぎです
調和を保ちましょう みんな仲良くしましょうと運動でも引き起こしてみてください
トラブルばっかりで周りから馬鹿にされるんです
あんた何か金が入る仕事でもしなさいよと
そんなバカなことをするなよと言われますよ
では 世界の平和は悪いと
いいえ 世界の平和はいいですよ
では あんた仕事をしてくださいという話になりますよ
もし誰かがこの 1 行で書いた 1
2 行で書いたようなね
もうみんな仲良く平和で幸せに調和を保って
他人に迷惑をかけないで生きてみようかなと言ってて
その目的によって活動を引き起こしちゃうと
もう弊害 攻撃 攻撃 攻撃
馬鹿にされちゃいます
その人々には人気がないんです
アメリカの歌の真似をしたら人気があるんです
なんか精神的な なんか神経に問題あって
なんかヒステリー起こしちゃうでしょ
あのヒステリック的に舞台の上でぐにゃぐにゃぐにゃぐにゃ体を動かしたら素晴らしい踊りですよと
その人は結構金も儲かります
ではみんなあの 例えばイラン戦争に反対運動やろうといったら
うるせえ あんたっていうことになるんです
何か気づいていない問題があります
だから何か個人的にも何か気づいてないことがあるんですね
それは自我の錯覚です
自分に自我という自分がいるという錯覚があるんです
錯覚っていうのは仏教用語で
皆様に当てて言えば 自分がいるという自覚が確実にあるんです
それは智慧で見たら錯覚なんです
騙されているんです はい
それはそれ 個人の問題ですね
では まあちょっと先行しましょう
疲れますかね 手が汚れている
手が汚れていると 何を触ってもそれで汚れるのです
傷がある手で汚れたものを触ると
汚れに感染しますね 自我の錯覚に気づかず
皆と共存 協力 行動しても
行為自体がやがて汚れてしまいます
だから手が汚れていると思った方がすごく理解しやすいんですよ
みんな本当に真面目なんです
本当に真面目で 良いことをしよう
良いことをしようとやっているんだけど
間もないうちに全部ダメになってしまいます
例えば どこかの国に行ってボランティアしようとね
水があまりもないところに行って
みんな汚れた水を飲んでいるんだから
では井戸を掘ってあげます
そういうプログラムを日本でやっていたんだから
今もやっているかもしれませんしね
で そこでみんな病気になって
子どもたちは死んだりする
それで あの ちょっといろんなところに井戸を掘ってあげて
掘ってあげて それである程度でキレイな飲める水を飲んで
まあ素晴らしいことでしょう
別に でもどこかでトラブっちゃうんです
どこかでうまくいかない
やってる人々は幸せ感じるはずなんですけど
くったくつかと あるいは協力してもらった側が本当に素晴らしい
なんてありがたいことやと思ってくれるはずなんですけど
あんまり反応が良くないと
いろいろあるんです なぜならば
やる人も受ける側も あげる側も受ける側も手が汚れているんですよ
手が汚れているということは
自我の錯覚があるんです
それが邪魔するんです
例えば あなたたちの井戸を掘ってあげたでしょうに
ではきれいな水飲めてよかったねと言ってみて
終わりです もう 言っちゃうでしょ
逆に自我のない人がこの水がないところで井戸を掘ってあげる
それで子供たちやらお母さんたちは井戸を汲んでね
それでみんなで集まったところで
本当にありがとうございます
こういうことを良いことをできて皆様に感謝しますと
皆様のおかげで私にも良いことできましたからといって
この井戸を掘ってもらった側に感謝すればぴったし受けるでしょ
その上 自我がないんです
これからこの村の人々には
何て言いますか 下痢とかなどなど病気にならないで
子供たちを廃人にしないで健康に生活できると思います
しっかりこの井戸を守って
みんなと仲良く協力しなさいと言って帰っちゃうと
1ヶ月も経たないうちに井戸を壊しちゃうんです
誰かが蹴っ飛ばしちゃうんですよ
そういうわけで この これは個人の問題の続きなんですけど
この手が汚れていることが問題なんです
どうも私は美味しい料理作っても
私の手が汚れているならば
料理自体は汚れているんです
あるいは私は美味しい料理作る
手袋をはめてあげる 受ける側の手が汚れているんだったらどうしますか？同じ結果でしょ
自我でわがままで非社会的な生き方をする人々を躾しようとしても
やがて自分の心も感染してしまいます
時々人間そうやるんです
この性格悪い人々に何かアドバイスでもして
カウンセリングでもやってあげて助けてあげようと
わがままな人 あるいは引きこもりの人
学校登校拒否する人 仕事に行かないでいる人とかね
じゃあこの人々にカウンセリングしてアドバイスしてあげればと
他人の精神的な問題を解決するそうと
まあ成功したことはないね
結局は そうやっていると
私も聞いたことあります
もう嫌だ この人毎日毎日いくら頑張っても結果がないやとかね
カウンセラーにもカウンセリングしなくちゃいけない羽目になっちゃうんです
だから感染していますよ
自分の自我が出てくるんです
自分がすごく丁寧に詳しくわかりやすくアドバイスしました
それからフォローアップもしました
後押しもしました 相手がやっていると褒めてあげたりもしましたが
自分の心はまた結局は何も何も結果がないんだと
ああ 嫌だこれはとかね
やる気がなくなったと
言って じゃあ私がカウンセリングしなくちゃいけないとかなるんですよ
カウンセラーが で その世界にあるよくあることで
だからカウンセラーにはもうこういうこういう
こういう風にやってくださいとか
いろんな教育はあるんだけど
結局はうまくいかない
いくらあっても自由は誰にも仏教以外
自分とは錯覚であるという一言も教えてないんです
これが自由だと思っている人々の
また自由独立を目指す人々の運命です
それこそが運命になっていますね
しかし 自我に気づかない
気づけない またひどいんですよ
自我に気づかない 気づかない
もと気づけないんです
気づけないんです この体に認識が生まれた瞬間で
自我が 自我の気配も起きるんです
それからどんどん強くなっていくんです
えーとですね これで前半は終わりました
はい では仏教の話に入りましょう
仏教はいつでも順番に進むべき真理の道なんです
ブッダは人の性格 能力に合わせて順番に自立の道を教えるのです
仏教は自立の道を教えるんですね
そちらにはしっかりしたプログラムがあるんです
その中で理解 理性 知恵という 3つの鍵がありますね
その 3つがないと仏教は成り立ちません
あの 盲信迷信ないんです
世界理性主義 世界と他人と戦うのではなく
自分の理解と理性を生かす生き方
そこでずっと我々今まで何やったかというと
世界と戦ってきたんですね
それは自我なんです 畑作る人も世界と戦っているんです
自分の好みに世界を合わせようとしているんです
船を作る人は自然法則と戦っているんです
俺の好みにしたいと 海で動きたいんだと
航海したいんだと そういうことで
すべての人類がこの自我を持って相手を敵にして戦っているんです
でも勝ったこともないし
苦しみが終わったわけでもない
なぜならば 苦しみを作っているのは世界じゃないんです
自分の自我なんです そこを直さないと
雪が降ったからといって私が困る必要ないんです
でも 私の自我がある場合は
あ 嫌だ 雪はとかね それで苦しくなるんです
私の家にいる娘一人が早く雪降ってくれないか
毎回ずっと調べたりとかね
だからその子はもしかすると雪が降ったならばね
今年降らないような気がしますけどもね
喜ぶでしょうね 私は嫌だなと思って部屋の中にいると思います
だからそれぞれでしょ
で どうしても自我がある場合は
この世界は敵ですね 人間も敵です
動物も敵です 環境も敵です
水も敵です 山も敵です
全部制覇しなくちゃいかんのです
自分がいるならばできる
これ錯覚だから はい そういうことで理性使ってみましょうよ
理性を使うと誰も私の敵ではありません
私のアプローチ次第だろうと
はい 順番で行きましょうか
まず体を観察しましょう
体のこと 体は自分のもののようで
自分のものではありません
そこから勘違いしています
自分の体だと思ってるでしょ
そのようで 本当はそうじゃないんです
物質は物質の法則に従って変わっていくんです
これ物質だから 私が言う通りに動かないんです
物質の物質の法則があるんです
ですから この体 なんか私のようなんですけど
実際私では私のものではありません
自分の自我が作る希望
好みは好み 期待は要らん
に 物質は応じない そこで自我があるんだから
私に希望があるわ 好みがあるわ
期待があるわ 物質ははい
わかりました 旦那様 ご主人様
あなたの希望通りにおいしくなりますと
あなたの希望通りに美しくなりますと
何ですかね 出かけると雨が
雨が降って嫌だ はい わかりましたと
雨がね ご主人様 じゃあ止んであげ
やめますと ある？そんなこと
だから雨が嫌だ嫌だと思ってる人は苦しみだけでしょうに
それが自我っていうことなんです
だから目の前に理性で見るとデータがあるでしょうに
隠れてないでしょうに
真理は この肉体は自分のものじゃないともあまりにもわかっているでしょ
わかり なんて言いますか
わかりすぎ しかし 見ないんです
面白いですよ どぎゃんと真理があるのに
真理はどこかどこかと
だからお釈迦様は無明を祝る盲目という単語を使っていますよ
だから生まれつき盲目だったら
これほら どこほら どこ？ほら
どこないでしょうと 目が開けたら論でしょうに
こうやって手でいた引きいたっても俺見つからないでしょうに
だからそんな感じで もう目の前にじりじりと死にでがあるのに気づかない
第一 体があなたのものじゃないっていうこと
しかし 物質の法則を理性理解すると
ある程度で体の調整はできる
それの理解が必要なんです
あ 物質はこういうものだ
物質はこんな感じで変化するのだ
だったらこういう風にした方が柔らかくなるんだ
こういう風にした方が硬くなるのだということは
ある程度で完璧にできませんよ
物質と違って 命が活動している物体は常に外の物質に依存します
また 物質も二つあるんですね
命の事務所 命が働いている場所
それは物質です 命が与えてないただの物質
ですから 命は機能する物質と命は機能していない物質
そんな難しくはないんですね
この物体はの中に命が与えている
このこちらは命が与えてない
そこで この物体とこの物体を比較してみると
この物体にいろんな物質を入れなくちゃいけないんです
こちらには入れないんです
外の物質に依存するんです
食事 飲み物 薬などが命をつなげるために必要です
食事やら飲み ただ物質でしょう
飲み物って物質でしょう
薬って物質でしょう そういうものをこの物体に入れなくちゃあかんですね
テーブルにはご飯をあげなくてもいいんです
テーブルには飲み物をあげなくてもいいんです
しかし テーブルのそばに座っている人に
飲み物やら食べ物やらあげなくちゃいけない
物体ことは二つですけど
だからといって自分が需要するものは自分のものでありません
また問題です 体も私のものではないし
体壊れるんだから食べ物とか入れたりする
物質を入れたりする それは物質も私のものじゃないんです
自我を張ることができません
だから自我を張ることは不思議で見るとできないんです
だって誰も私の好みに動いてないでしょう
に ラーメン食べたかったのにご飯しかご飯しかないんですね
俺はラーメン食べたいんだから
ご飯ラーメンになりなさい
なってくれませんね 自我は通らないんですよ
だからいつでも私は 例えば電話でピザを注文したっても
自我が通じているように見えますけど
そうじゃないんです ピザを注文するときは
あのリストを見て何か選ばなくちゃあかんでしょ
自分好みの自分バージョンのピザ注文できるんでしょ？そこでやられてますね
そこで金額書いてるでしょ
それに払わなくちゃいけない
すぐ持ってきていたっても
電話したら 30分時間かかるんで
30分待たなくちゃいけないんです
それで自我は張る 結局は風が吹いたから枝が揺れた
それだけの話 風がなくても枝が揺れてやるとはできませんよ
あるいは風が吹いているのに揺れてやらねよと
それできません なんでそういう目に前にある目の前にある事実を無視するんですかね
自我を張ることはできません
理解して賢くになった方がいいでしょう
結局っていうのは自我張らないなと
イライラしない ピザ注文したらもう早く食べたいんだけど
それは自我 電話は向こう側からね
今ちょっと天気も悪いし
注文たくさんあるんだから
40分後 40分ぐらいになりますけど
いかがでしょうかと  40分は待てと言ったら来ませんね
自我あったら状況はそうなってるんだったら
まあしょうがないね はい
お願いしますでしょ 権利はないということを覚えてください
もう体のこと終わった
食べなければ死にますが
食べ物は取る権利はないんです
これは膨大なブッダの教えをものすごく縮まって言うんだから覚えておいてください
この 1 行 each は大事なんです
地球の中にたくさんアイデアがあるんです
食べるものを取る権利がないんです
それは理解しましょう
理解できないんだったら
例えば例を出します 自分に食べられるために豚が生まれて成長しているのではないでしょう
豚さんが人間に食べてほしいと
だからいっぱい食べますとかね
なんでお前いっぱい食べるの？だって太った方が人間にはたくさん肉が入りますから
と そんなことないでしょ
だから豚を食べる権利がないんです
じゃあご飯 稲が人間様に食べさせてあげたいと見なる？ないんですよ
そこで私には 私は笑っちゃうのはバナナって一体何なのかと
バナナはバナナの木に入らない
バナナの木というんですかね
あれは木ではないんだけどね
長部なんとかバスなんとかですね
なんとか植物ですね 全然要らないです
だから私はバナナだけは法則違反やと
だって美味しいバナナ作って自分では要らないし
だったらもう食べるしかないんですね
マンゴーはそうじゃないんです
マンゴーはもう狙いがもうあるんですね
だから仕事してもらうんだから
マンゴーは じゃあこれ給料あなたの
バナナはそうじゃないんです
じゃあ食べちゃい だからバナナだけちょっと法則違反ですね
だから私は冗談で言うのはバナナ以外は食べる権利はないんです
食事をいただくもの 借りるもの
恵みなんです 恵みっていうのは
このちょっとあの 例えばこのものをこう人々はあの恵み
あの意味の恵みなんです
あるいは借りるんですね
借りると言ったっても
例えば豚を食べる場合は残酷でしょう
豚を殺すんですね ですから
節度を知って食べるか
食べるために生きているのではないと理解しましょうよ
だって人類作ったこの食い食い文化
食文化 もうすごいこと
だからそんないらん フランス料理あれば
中華料理あれば ユダヤ料理あるわね
インド料理あるわ メルリ
ミッドイースト料理あるわ
インドネシア料理あるわね
インドネシア ラオス タイもまたそれぞれ隣隣合わせの国ですけど
食事が違う文化でしょうし
そこまでやる  そこまでやっているのは
それで苦しみがなくすだろうと思っていたんです
しかし 中華食べても一生フランス食べても糖尿病になるバカが
残念ながら糖尿病になりますね
高血圧になる人は何通り食べたってそうなるんです
インド料理食べたらこれ糖尿病にならないなりますよ
いくらでもいますから
だから何やってるのかなんです
意味がないじゃないですかと
だから節度を知っていただけば
お借りしますと あ これ恵みやと思っちゃうと
自我が働かないんです
例えば 信玄菜でしたっけ？なんかあの下丸い葉っぱありますね
あれは私は食べたいんだけど
中国から輸入するものは絶対日本で作ったものしか食べない
料理にはニンニク入れたいんだけども
どこ見ても中国から輸入したもの
いやいやいや 青森さんないんですか？ないんですかとか
結構自我張ってるでしょうね
だから変でしょ？権利すらないのに
だから理性ある人にとっては信じられない
この生き方 当然ニンニク食べますけど
ニンニク入れたらこれ食べる権利がないんです
なんでそれ理解しないんですかね
これ罠ですよ 物体があるでしょうに
体という この物体に品物を入れなくちゃあかんですね
なのに品物提供してくれません
それってすごく 何て言いますか
イラショナルというかね
もうすごいエリコイスでしょう
エリコイスではない すごい
なんか変ですね 例えば地球で生まれた人間にはご飯を食べなくちゃいけないならば
もう自然界で米が現れてきて
食いなさい 食いなさいと言わなくちゃいけないでしょうに
食いなさいと言わなくても
例えばどこかで私は住んでいるとしましょう
そこら辺 私が住んでいる周りでどんどん稲が出てきて
そうするとそれを取って食べられると
それで私は出て行ったら稲が出てこない
ならばOKなんです そうじゃないでしょうに
水も飲まなくちゃいけないのに
水はあげない状態なんです
だから取る羽目になっているんです
仏教はいくらかこの法則から抜けているのは水と空気だけなんです
他 強引に取っています
だからそこで謙虚でやられているんだから
謙虚でいただくっていうことがね
あるいは借りるという気持ちが必要です
食べ物は借り物だから返せる方法もあるのでしょうかと考えた方がいいよ
借りばっかしでは だから 1食食べると1食借りなんです
何かしら返さないと じゃあ仏教の習慣
私たちはこの法則的に法律的に決まっていないんだけれど
自分のご飯食べる前に一部置いておくんです
誰かにあげるということにするんです
日本では難しいんだけど
日本ではごみ箱に捨てるしかないんだけど
自然界でここまで自我張ってないんだからね
我々はまだ自然界ありますから
自分の皿から一部を外へ出しちゃえば
誰かが来て食べる だから誰かにあげているんです
あげたものが そのどんな生命にでも食べることは権利があるんです
だから意図的に私は他の生命に権利を作ってあげたんだ
食べる権利を そうすると私の借りが今借りたんだからね
借りが消えるんです 必ず昔は自分の故郷の田舎ではね
お母さんたちは米 人数分米を測って釜に入れるんですね
入れてからそこから一部をこうやって手に握り取って
何かに入れておくんです
大体このお寺のこの仏像を作ったり
お寺の本堂を修復したり
これする場合はあれは持っていってあげるんです
で だからなんか人間が信仰ばっかしではないかと思っても
深い哲学があるんです
私も知ってますよ もう今やってないと思いますけど
米測って釜に入れたら一部取ってわざわざ手で取るんです
その場合でも 手で取って別なものに入れておく
いくらなんでもそれは使いません
それはあげるものです
だから今食べられるものがあるんですね
それで借りたんだからあげるということで
返すということを考えているんですね
でも私は今喋る哲学はひとかけらもあの方々は知らないんで
ただお釈迦様がおっしゃっていることからやっているんですね
自我の病が生きる権利があると思う
私たちはみんな生きる権利があると思っているんですね
ないんです そうないんです
自我があるんだから 俺に生きる権利があるんだぞと思っちゃうんです
しかし 命を支えるものはすべて借り物です
権利あるんだったら 堂々と王様の気分で生きていられればいいですね
でしょうに よく考えると
着るもの 住むところ 食べるもの
薬などなど 命を支えるものは全部借りて借りて借りて借りてやっているんです
そこで在家の方々はそれに気づかないんだから
我々出家にははっきりとあなたは借りて食べているんだよと
だから借りがないようにしなさいと
要するに 自我の錯覚をきれいさっぱり消したら
解脱に達したならば もうアナノーという言葉を使うんです
借りがないんです 僕はみんな借り
在家の人にそんなこと言っちゃうとものすごく嫌がるんだから
あまり在家向きの話でもないんで
私は全部ごちゃまぜにして今喋っているんです
皆様あまり喜ぶ話じゃないんで
皆様だったら 我々はせっかく人間に生まれたんだから
生きる権利あるでしょう
幸せになる権利あるでしょう
世界制覇する権利あるでしょう
言った方が気分がいいでしょ
あれは自我なんです 病気です
何としてでも生きなくてはという考えが間違いだと理解すると
今私は解決策をずっと言っています
理解しましょうと はい
次 心に体のことは終わり
心が認識活動しないと生きられません
食べるものだけじゃないで
心が回転しないと あの
例えば心が認識しない場合は植物人間というでしょ
死にますよ もう 認識活動するためには
色相 光 名色法に依存しなくてはならない
が 色相光名色法 自分のものでも自分の希望通りに働くものでもありません
私には生きるために感覚が必要です
それで刺激が生まれてエネルギーが生まれるんで
ものを見ると じゃあ見るものは私のもの
今ホールを見てるでしょ？私のもの
すべて色相光名色法も私のものじゃないんです
自分の希望通りに働かないんです
色声香味触法を自分のものを自分の財産にしようとしているが
そちらに無理があるのだと理解しましょう
しかし 人間が色声香味触法を取ってやろう
取ってやろう 取ってやろうと
そればっかりやっているんで
家を作りたいでしょ？土地を買いたいでしょ
服を買いたいでしょ？お化粧品も買いたいでしょ
これ 色声香味触法なんです
服を買ってもどんなメーカーでしょうかというと
妄想の快楽でしょ あるいは色声香味触の法の方なんです
妄想するだけ だからあの服は私の
この家が私の この貯金が私のと
あるわ あるわ あるわ 人間ずっとそれやってますよ
世界で仕事をしていると何やってますかね？色声香味触法を私のものにしてやろうと頑張っているんです
私のものにならないんです
だからそこに相当無理があるんです
無理が結構利いてますよ
結構利いてます 例えば土地やら家やら買ってみてください
ちょこちょこちょこちょこと
相当ひどい目にあうんですよ
無理をやればやるほど苦しみが増えるんです
憂い 悲しみ 悩みが起こるんです
だから世間で経済活動をやっています
仕事をしています 事業を起こしてますとか
偉そうなことを言うでしょ
ただ 悩み苦しみを育ててますと言った方が早いんです
だから罠ですよ それやらなくちゃいけないんだけど
権利がないこと はい それからもう体のこと終わった
心のこと終わった では
他の生命のことにいきましょう
できるだけ省略します
命は他の生命の働きで成り立っています
かわいそう 自分では生きられません
他の生命が生かしてもらわないと
他の生命 他の生命が自分の命を生かしているんです
自分が支配者でも支配されているのでもありません
そこにまた自我が張り込んできて
変なことをするんです
家族がいると楽に生きられますよ
自分が家族の支配者ですかね
だって体の中で無数の生き物がいるでしょ？それなかったらもうどうにもならない
食べるものは消化できないし
消化したものは吸収できないし
吸収したものはエネルギーに入れ替えてくれないし
細菌を退治しなくちゃいけないし
これは自分でやってなくて
他人がやっているんです
私の体に細菌が入っちゃうと
他の生命体が体の中にいて
それが潰してくれるんです
ですから私は 私の体の白血球ティーセルスの何て言いますか
支配者 お医者さんたちよく知ってますね
人のあれ 白血球数えて
あなたちょっと異常に増えている
これは危険だとか あなたには白血球はすごく数が少ない
これは異常だ 危険だとか
だったら先生に聞いて
先生どれぐらい低い？白血球
これぐらい はい わかりました
作ります できませんね
あなたの白血球の数がありすぎ
これ危険ですと あ そう
じゃあ減らせます できないでしょ？自我が通らないんです
結局はどうすれば減らせますかと聞かなくちゃいけないです
そこでみんなよく人を支配したい
環境を支配したい 他人の国を支配したい
家族を支配したい なんだこれ
これで悩み苦しみが生まれるでしょ
だからトランプさんも仏教を語っています
トランプさんが頭いいから出るでしょうね
だから支配したいでしょ
何でもかんでも 地球丸ごと
それでいかに地球に危険かと
いかに人間の財産なくなるのかと
関係ある人ない人も死ぬ羽目になるでしょう
だから支配したがるっていうことは何なのかね
自我だからわからない
この連中が 他の命がないと自分という命が成り立たない
だから支配者じゃないんです
支配しようと思っちゃうと
向こうが敵に回すんです
では自分が支配されているのかというと
まあせいぜいウイルスですね
ウイルスに感染したら
ウイルスは私たちを支配しちゃうんですね
でも そのうち体の他の生命体があれを追い出すんです
だからそんな長持ちはしません
命はネットワークです
この単語を使って覚えてください
命っていうのはネットワークです
自分という端末がなくてもネットワークに問題ありません
だから自分という命 一個の命はどうでもいいんです
ネットワークにとっては
私の携帯があってもなくても
ネットワークシステムに問題ある？全然
それ理解します だからそこを理解すれば自我が通わなくなっちゃうんです
ですから 正しくコミュニケーションして
幸せに安穏に生きることは自分の行為
反応次第になります  自分がネットワークであると理解して
正しい情報をネットワークに送信して
必要な情報をネットワークからいただくということで
それでバランスを整えれば
この人の悩み苦しみがないんですね
自悲喜捨の情報をネットワークに送信するべきだと仏教が語る
なぜ仏教はものすごく自悲喜捨を喋っているかというと
面倒くさいんだから こんなややこしい話お釈迦様ならしません
すごいシンプルに喋るんです
人間ね あんたね 日夜すべての生命を慈しんでください
はい 帰ってちょうだい
終わり その人の問題はすべて解決します
お釈迦様おっしゃっているのは
あなたネットワークにとても大事なデータをあげてくださいなんです
全ネットワークにどうしても欠かせないデータをこちらで送信する
あのWikipediaに記事を書く方々みたいにね
お金ももらいませんよ
もしかすると でもすごく真剣に丁寧に研究して記事を出すんですよ
それで我々は無料でその記事を読むんです
だからそこよくわかるでしょう
ウィキペディアででたらめ書けないでしょ？でたらめ書いたら誰かがこれ間違い
これ間違いと言って訂正しちゃうんだから
書いた人はそれで批判
自然界で受けるんです
だから正しい言い方には
ウィキペディアはすごくいい例なんです
うん そういうわけで 知識人が
学者たちがウィキペディアに記事を載せるような感じで
一人一人の生命が自記者を生命ネットワークに送信する
そうすると向こう側からは幸福がものすごく受信できるんです
僕は幸福 幸せ 安らぎ 安穏を送ってくれるんです
だから面倒くさいんだから
お釈迦様は慈悲記者やってくださいとすごい簡単に教えたんです
はい 自由 自立が失う原因
他を支配すること 支配されることで自由が失います
他を支配したら 支配者に自由がない
支配される人にも自由がない
我が子との関係であっても法則は同じです
我が子であっても支配してはいけませんよ
逆に支配されてもいけません
子供に どういうことでしょ？今の親は
子供を支配することも
子供に支配されることも避けるんです
命との関係はギブアンドテイクの関係です
ギブの方がテイクより大きい関係が安全です
逆は不幸の原因です 本当はこれゼロは良くないんです
ポイントギフトしてポイントいただいちゃうとゼロでしょ
バランスは良くないです
いつでも安全な態度はギフトの方が大きくて
テイクの方が少なくて
なんてテイクではなくて
私は使う方はレシーブなんです
いただく で その方がちょっと少ない方が一番安全です
見返りを期待しないで望まないで
ギブのみの喜ぶ人は最高の幸せを感じます
だからこのギフトの一番トップはギフトだけで
で いらない 別に必要ない
間に合ってます だったらなんであげるの？それは楽しいということなんです
社会関係を築く はい これからはもうグループ活動に入ります
ギブアンドテイクの関係は自然で普通です
しかし テイクだけ期待する
それ人間像なんです テイクだけ取ることだけしか考えない
またはギブを極力少なくするように企む
その人が賢い人もいるでしょ
あまり自分であげるものはなく
結構ボロ儲けしたとか
これが社会の問題で 社会にその問題があるんです
人間が会社 工場何でもこのできるだけたくさん儲かりたいんですね
自分あげるものはそんな価値がないんです
ギブ大きいテイクの場合は
そう 日本語で読むのはそういうことですかね
ギブイズラージザンテイクということで
人になれば苦しい社会で苦しみがなく生きられます
だから社会で苦しくなく生きられれば生きたければ
方法 秘密はギフトが大きくてテイクは少ない
ギブ大きいテイクの関係を作ることが個人の行為です
だからディスイズラージャーダンテーっていう関係が
それを作るのは自分なんです
それで自分が幸せになるんです
他人に期待するものではない
他人に説教する必要もないんです
他人も真似すれば幸せになります
だから自分がしてあげる
してもらう方はもうまあ少なくても結構それで十分満足すると
周りももしかすると真似するかもしれません
だからあなたもそうしない
あなたもそうしなさいと余計な説教はいらないとは思います
それからどうやって社会関係を築くのかという仏教バージョン
それは道徳の関係です
仏教のグループはあれやこれやグループ
なんとか活動とかあったでしょ
それは純粋道徳の関係です
それで皆様道徳の意味がわからないんだからね
今日は道徳論じゃないんだからね
道徳って一応定義します
正しい生き方 生きるべき生き方
それだけです 例えば 誤解を守る会
怒りを克服する会 心を清らかにするための会などなど
まあグループ作ってくださいよと
俗世間はもうもうできるだけ take take ばっかしの会でしょ
だからハチャメチャ問題トラブルなんですよ
どんなもう組織でもあってもね
問題ばっかしで 会長は誰にするのかとかね
この会長はもう本当に一年で早く辞めてほしいとか
でも会長も俺がもう一年
もう一年やってやるぞとかね
こんな世界っていうのはね
気持ち悪いです  五年間アメリカの支配するトランプさんが
我々私から見れば明日でもいいんだから家に戻れと言いたいんだけど
この人はあと五年やるつもりでしょ
それっていうのは明らかにそういう人々の生き方で人類が不幸になるんです
だから 俗世間にあるどんないかなるソサエティ
いかなるクラブであっても
苦しみの原因になるんです
楽しくはないんです ブッダが思想的に道徳会作ってくださいよと
例えば誤解を守る会で会長は誰ですかとか関係ないでしょ
道徳は二種類です 道徳っていうのは二種類です
内からこみ上げる悪感情を制御すること
一つ 内から心の中から悪感情こみ上げてくるんです
それは制御するんです
それは道徳です 自分の行為で他の生命に迷惑をかけないこと
自分が生きていると生命にはすごい迷惑なんです
ブッダさんかわいそうでしょ？魚もかわいそうでしょ
それで自我があると その人の生き方はもう非道徳ばっかしなんです
だから道徳の 2番目は
自分の行為で他に迷惑をかけないように
他の生命に気をつける
例えば不殺生戒あるでしょ
自分は生きる生命は殺さないんですね
だから自分の行為で生命には迷惑はないんです
嘘をつかないということは
人を騙さないということですよ
だから他人が迷惑 他人に迷惑はかけないんです
ブッダのこの 2つの目的を達成するために
仲間 組織 グループを作ることを推薦します
だから一人ではちょっと難しいんだから
仲間を作ってよと グループ作っちゃえばいい
しかし これは 俗世間にあるギターを弾く会とかね
ピアノでというものじゃないんです
道徳会です 自分の錯覚が破りに破りにくいんですよ
自我の錯覚 本当にたちが悪いんです
自我の気持ちは普通だと思う
なぜならば 自分がやると普通でしょうと思っているんですね
自我こそが唯一尊いものだと思っているんです
ヨーロッパの文化ではね
尊い不死なる魂が神様からいただいているんだよと
この自我の錯覚に対して言うんです
どれほど勘違いかと アジアになってくると
神様の分身であると ヒンドゥー教だったら
神様が塵みたいにただとなっと分解しちゃって個人になっています
錯覚を破る目的の仲間がいれば
互いに助け合ったり より深く問題を理解したり
負けそうになると励ましてもらったりすることができます
だから人類やってないことだから仲間を作った方がいい
そうするとお互いに教えてもらったりする
自分が別に何とも思わないでやったことは
もしかすると自我あったことかも
それは自我あったことでしょうと言ってくれる人が欲しいんです
あんた怒ったでしょと言ってくれる人が欲しいんですね
それから頑張ると負けそうになりますね
自我をなくすことに頑張ると負けそうになります
その時は励ましてもらう人が必要なんです
ブッダが比丘たちにサマッガーナンタポスく仲良し同士で修行は楽ですと説かれています
これは今日ほとんど在家に教えたものを遍礼参考にしていないんだけど
全て比丘たちに教えたものからデータまとめたんだけど
修行は仲良し同士だったらすごい楽ちんだよと
俗世間的な目的でできている社会システム
組織 会 グループ クラブが無数にあります
自我の癌に栄養を与える結果になります
社会のグループ行動はすべて自我の癌に栄養を与えるんです
作るべきなのは道徳の会なんです
だから仏教は世間でない組織
グループを作るんです
それで例としてサンガ組織
これは随分初めからお釈迦様が作っちゃったんです
ブッダが出家にサンガ組織を作ったんです
煩悩を断ち 解脱に達する目的の組織です
サンガクラブと言いたいんだけど
ちょっと面倒くさくなりますから
あの単語はね サンガ組織
で サンガ組織の目的は煩悩を根絶することなんです
解脱に達することなんです
他人に真理を語って組織以外の人々も助けるんです
それからサンガはもう一つやります
組織の仲間でなくても
一般的な人々にも真理を何の戸惑いなく教えてあげるんです
フリーで教えるんです
これは自我の錯覚があっても自我を張れない組織です
例えばサンガ みんな悟っているわけじゃないんです
出家した人には自我があるんです
しかし 出家した時点から自我が張れなくなるんです
自我あっても微妙にサンガ組織の決まりができているんです
すごい精密に だから出家には自我が張れなくなるんです
失敗する方々もたまにいるんだけど
特に我々は伝統的にテーラワーダだから
伝統的なではない民族から出家する人々は結構トラブったりはしますけどもね
できるだけ教えようとはする
理解しない方々はまた減速してもらうんです
先輩後輩 経験者 見習いなどの差がありますよ
人間のグループだから
しかし 会員は皆平等です
このブッダのグループでは
会員はみんな平等です
その中で先輩もいるし
後輩もいるし 経験者もいるし
見習いもいる アドバイザーがいても支配者はいない
だから自分に悩むことがあったら
サンガの中で誰かに聞く
知ってる人には私を選んだから
あの人に聞いて聞け 聞けと言ったら
その人に聞く 教えてくれる
個人が過ちを犯しても
それを正す方法も組織の決まりとして設定しているので
批判する される 非難する
非難を受けるなどの問題もありません
これ 組織なる問題なんですね
批判する あなたのやり方はこれが良くないとかね
あるいはもう非難 批判ではなくてね
受けたりもする それはサンガの中でないんです
サンガも人間だから いろいろ過ちを犯したりしますよ
知らないうちに それで過ちを犯したら
その過ちはどうやって正すのかという方法もお釈迦様は完璧に教えているんです
それをしてもらえばいいんです
誰が偉いお坊さんがこら
あなたも過ちを犯したでしょうと言う必要はないんです
言わない 本当は出家はこういう風にしましょうと教えてあげるだけで
出家の決まりだよと 何かを決める場合は多数決ではなく
深海一致です  あと10分くらいであと10分くらいで終わらせて
分 分  10分 はい あ 質問の時間なくなっちゃう
異論があるならば それがブッダの教えと戒に従ったものでなければ無効です
サンガには異論があってもいい
私はもうちょっと違う意見だよと
意見聞いて あ それはブッダの教えに合ってない
だから無効と それは 修行は個人の宿題ですので
個人は攻撃 個人攻撃は成り立ちません
ちょっとわかりにくい
そこでサンガとして 仲間として
サンガも4種類いますけど
仲間でで仲良く活動する
繁栄する しかし 解脱に達することは個人の宿題です
だから他人に何とも言う権利もないんです
戒を守りたくない ブッダの教えに反対という気持ちになった時点で
サンガのメンバーシップが自然に失いますので
サンガ組織が衰落しない
衰退 衰退しない できない
例えば汚れた人がいると
サンガのグループの中で
その人ブッダの教えに従っていないならば
もうとっくにメンバーシップが消えているんです
だからサンガが困った困った
なんか変な人が入っちゃったとか思わなくていいんです
今までそう思うこともない
変な人はありますよ 入ってきたのは自然に外へ出せます
外に出す 捨てられます
また 一切の民族差別は認めない組織です
微塵も人民族差別ない
背が高いか低いか 黒いか白いか
一切禁止です 道徳組織会などを作ることが大事です
ですから  4種類のサンガでしょ？在家の男性
在家の女性 出家の男性
出家の女性 それぞれ自分自分好みのグループを作るのは一向に構わない
しかしそれは道徳会でなければいけません
自立 体 体が物体なので
生きることは他の生命との共同作業なので
自立は論理的に不可能です
だから姿勢を持ちましょう
自立はできません 肉体ある限り
だって物質だから 自我の錯覚のせいで自分が自由だ
自立しているのだと思うことが最大の問題です
自立を誇示すると 生命ネットワークのサポートがなくなるので
自分が作った地獄の苦しみに陥ります
だから自我を誇示 自立
自立 私は自立と独り立ちで言っちゃうとサポートが切れちゃいます
あれ 病院でライフサポートを受けているような感じで
私は自立してるんだと言ったら
看護師さんがあれ 吸入します
さようならと自分で呼吸できるんだからと言ったら
ああ そう はい よ 自立とは
心が何ものにも依存しない境地に達することです
みんな自立理解していない
心が何にも依存しない
体ではないんです 心が何にも依存しないことが自立なんです
では 心の問題にやりましょう
認識過程を観察する だって問題は肉体じゃないんです
心を自立させるんです
だから肉体は自立できんとそこで諦めておこう
頑張らない できない 心は
心はできる その方法はあります
認識過程観察してください
自我の錯覚が非論理的にものの物の影のように現れる様子を発見します
この自我の錯覚が物の影のように現れる過程を発見しましょう
目で物を見ると 自我の物の影が現れる
耳で音を聞くと 自我の物の影が現れる
鼻で香りを嗅ぐと 自我の物の影が現れる
その過程を ABCDEF あ
違うという風に発見してみれば
生きていきたい 死にたくはないという存在欲
生きることは尊い 永遠不滅の至福のの
のみ至福のみを感じる
魂があるなどの無知な邪見が自我の錯覚の産物であると発見します
だからすごい智慧が現れますよ
世の中の知識に何にも依存しない
みんなただ錯覚の産物だとわかってるんです
だってあるでしょ？命は尊い
あれやこれやとかね 魂は至福のみあるものだと
自我の錯覚が破れるとも
と ものだけではなく 自分に執着することも依存することも消えるんです
人間に理解できない状態になるんです
ものにも執着しない 世界にも執着しないだけ
体にも執着しないだけではなくて
自分自身の存在にも執着しないんです
現象は無常で流れるだけになる
悟ったら現象は流れるだけ
私がいません そうなるんです
この境地が真の自律です
それに本当の自律はそこにあるんです
自律メッセ集団 読んでみます
読むだけでね あの一 仲間に対して
公でも内緒でも慈しみの考えを持つ
実践する 集団を作ったら
一人一人に責任がある
グループのグループに対して一人で考える
あいつは何なのかね あの人は思ったわかん
思うでしょ 皆様 組織の中でグループでニコニコとして家に帰ったら
あの人のあの態度は何なのかねとかね
あれは俗世間の場合は
仏教のグループ活動の場合は
グループでいる時でもグループを離れても
あの人は本当に幸せであります
あの人も幸せでありますようにと思うなくちゃいかんのです
みんなの心が清らかになりますようにとか
仲間に対して 公でも内緒でも慈しみの言葉を使う
あ 間違った 仲間に対しても
公でも内緒でも慈しみの行為をする
思考 言葉 行為 慈しみでやらなくちゃいけない
四 他人に推薦する 教える
慈しみだけ他人にも教えてあげる
カルマもいた ウペッカーもこのように実践しますが
だいたい見ただけで十分です
それで自分の自我という癌が完全に取り除けることができるような状況が整います
何のことなく 自我という癌をピシッと取ってあげることができるようになります
こういう風にグループ活動をすれば
取り除く手術は自分で行う
しかし 自我の癌を取り除く手術は自分でやらなくちゃいけない
手術で 他人であることですけど
この場合はこうなるんです
やっておりました ありがとうございます
[拍手] はい 最後の聖歌文章で終了しましょう
はい ご一緒にお願いします
ドゥッカッパッターチェニン ドゥッカッバヤン パッターチェニン バヤ ソーカン パッターチェ ニン ソーカ ホントゥ サンベーティ パニノー
苦しむものの苦しみがなくなりますように
怯えるものの怯えが消えますように
悲しむものの悲しみがなくなりますように
一切の生命が幸福のごとくありますように
はい どうもありがとうございます
カンティー パラマン タポー ティティッカー ニッバーナ パラマン ワダンティー ブッダ